给大家介绍几个赚钱的方法,肯定不会亏,因为没什么成本,我看很久老伙,老洋高点,服务业,赚点外块,代表不好,干点上,然后往上的信息就不太可靠,所以我给大家找几个石头几的,你看了,就能做了这么一个方法,看从那开始,咱们先从简单的开始,然后再说咱一言的,又上一模式了,我发现很多人,时间都被浪费掉了。
就你有大量的时间是为显置,比如排队的时候,通情的时候,等待的时候,有时候我坐地小,看好似,下的电影,然后听小说,然后听越,本来就是打发时间,其实你通情的时间可以做很多事,我给大家久了一个,其实是个真实的,就是你通情的段时间,可能20分钟就做爆了,你想一想,你平时用那些显置的商品,比如说,你买了钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱钱,你买了钱钱钱钱钱钱钱
什么运动相机,对吧,你买了一个小平板,什么样的东西,这个用是显置的,其实你很少用,或者几乎不用,你放了那段话就会浪费,而且在用的思源,然后你可以把它这个星期整理一下,越早越好,然后把它放到二手平台上,这个过程就是让你去严证,一个把东西销束出去的,这么一个过程,然后你可以收起小的时候的东西,刚开始买自己的,后来可以买家人的,然后可以买其他人的,我去运动,
今年7月份的时候给大家分享过一个姑娘,就是口罩期间,然后呢,他不上学嘛,然后他就把自己的小时候的一些玩具,小时候东西放到晚上买,就买了特别好,后来慢慢的,他又专门去世上去逃,那种玩耳术的,尤其是平时比较贵的,他逃完了一个的话,重新整理,然后再上价,然后就开始买,现在做的,做的就非常大了,然后之前给他分享过,就是我之前时候朋友干嘛,专门收那种微货,
不能卖不住的你就会过一些大盼,收回来以后,然后重新冒装一下,去做快想电,对吧,在淡这个成本特别低,就是平时什么时候是,这个二十分钟,对吧,然后把一些显示上给卖出去,这是一个练手的过程,后面那个部分,稍微复杂解了,但是你是可以做的,大家如果去往上看,就那个网友不说,因为我后面都会说一些网站的,因为人就会判定我已经留,只剩出现过,把你就找可能是有的,就是有人把那个带,
带的演讲,大家都知道他演讲,非常好这个演讲素财,他会把那个他演讲,就是整理出来,中英文双语,然后把他做成很精美的,就在买了卖,我一看,还有卖的不少了,老少吧,不少了啊,你们就看啊,他是有的,那么我给大家出一个小主意什么呢,就你还从前呢,还从前呢,二十分钟三十钟钟,有人三十分钟怎么办呢,你许往上去找,那种比如说一下油管,的一些波课,一些放谈,你想,对吧,想,
什么啊,对吧,这样的一些方单,特别有价值,然后听到,听到,听到关系的段落,你把他标击上,回来把这段给他接去出来,对吧,就把他整理成机,就只思料包,或者把他做成一些段视频,就放在短视频平台上,油啊,你们就往上搜,而且有人做得不错,做得非常好,这都是真实的案例啊,这个,最次最次的话,你这个位置可以学到一些东西嘛,对,可以学很多东西,顺便可以装到小钱,然后第三个的话,
其实你都不需要动脑,但都不需要有什么创作能力,还是呢,大家就往上找一些图下来的,就是不是视频的一些,你去搜,比如说本地,周末而从活动,你就搜,这种关键刺,你就搜肯定是有的啊,比如说9月份的8月份的而中活动啊,对吧,或者是没搜到这个而中活动啊,可能是静元的,就免费的,但是比较好的一些而中活动,你把它整理出来,有人哦,就真的把它做成色选,好像是9块9,然后一个月不老少啊,我,我,我,我看来,
啊,你得别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别,别别,别,别,
學生堅持信息 現在也有
你們就差
所以各位 你看
這幾個都是可以利用
言語事件去搞定的
剛開始你可以把二手的商品拿出來去去
有一個銷售的過程
然後你可以利用信息差 對吧
比如說這邊有那邊沒有
然後你可以把這些支持
自己處理完了以後
可以搬一搬一搬
還有的話就是有些
幫別人省事
別人也可以做
但是你幫他去塞選
幫他去國旅 幫他去提醒
我們很多人認為
賺錢就一定是句話
打的時間要大量的人
對不對
但隨意上的話
其實很多時候
賺錢就是去找一些很小的
別人不太在乎的一些價值
然後利用系統的工具
把它放大
所以個錢並不一定在大塊的時間
錢就藏在那些
你看不起的極不欺騙的
那個零歲的時間裡